welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka definition and
I'm devastated that I've opened the
video with one of the worst puns ever
anyway if you hear chances are you've
been watching Deb's on FX it's an
absolutely outstanding show that has
several mysteries surrounding it namely
what is it that the devs do in order to
explain that we have to explain the
machine itself how it operates and white
cement several things about the universe
throughout this video we'll be
discussing everything you need to know
about the computer and if it's accurate
or not there will be heavy spoilers here
so if you haven't watched up to episode
7 yet then I highly recommend that you
turn off now the universe has already
decided whether you will watch this
video or not it does not matter
everything will happen the way that it's
supposed to
you will also subscribe if you aren't ok
I'll not push it anyway please drop a
like if you enjoy the video now let's
get into our breakdown of devs okay so
dev centers around a tech company called
Amaya the company is named after the
daughter of the CEO who tragically died
yes prior and the machine in devs is as
much about bringing him closure as it is
of bringing him agony over what could
have been we'll get into this more later
but the CEO Forrest and his company have
made leaps and bounds in terms of
software and programming this has caught
the attention of several agencies and
governments namely Russia who sent in a
spy named Sergei to run reconnaissance
on the mysterious deaths department that
exists within the company Sergei works
his way up is brought in and sees
firsthand what goes on there and he
tries to smuggle out the information but
is captured and killed
Amaya cover up his death and sergey x'
girlfriend lili tries to uncover exactly
what's going on
which leads her to the machine that's a
basic part of a view but there's a lot
more going on as well as an absolutely
incredible soundtrack anyway in order to
understand the MacGuffin that is the
machine we have to understand how the
universe itself works at the dawn of
time there was the Big Bang which sent
atoms across the universe eventually
they form planets and created life as we
know it humans came into existence and
then they live lives had children who
went on to have children and
civilization was created everything from
the Big Bang all the way until this very
moment has followed a pathway a chain of
events that have led us to the here and
now even you yes you sitting there
watching this video at this very moment
you are here because everything in your
life that has happened so far has led
you to this moment
in fact scratch that everything in not
only your life but your parents lives
your grandparents their parents and
everyone in your family tree dating back
to the second that your ancestors
stepped out of the ocean that has all
led you here
so yeah this with this video better be
good I guess now what the machine are
devs has done is that it's taken every
single thing on the planet
and traced it back in time accurately
recreating events from human history it
is then mapped them out into a complex
algorithm and using this data it spotted
out what will happen in the future it's
extremely complicated but they do a
brilliant job of explaining it in the
show with these of a pen
when you roll a pen on a table it almost
seems ran and whereabouts it will stop
however if you were to take this speed
that the pen was rolled the direction it
was sent into the weight of it and all
of the variables that make it this
specific pen you would not only be able
to see how far forward it would roll but
you would also be able to trace it back
to its point of origin therefore if you
had this information you could predict
both its past movements and its future
devs basically says that there are no
random events absolutely none everything
on earth is the way that it is because
of cause and effect even a coin flip can
be predicted if you know the weight of
the coin the speed in which it was
flipped the surface it will land on and
more basically that is what the machine
does it takes all of the information for
everything on the planet and then it
uses this to betray exactly how things
have been and how they will be at one
point when Sergey looks over the code he
states that if this is true then it
changes everything
however this is quickly rebuffed by
Katie who says no if it's true
then it changes absolutely nothing
everything is on a preordained path
because of what has happened in the past
and there is no way to really divert
from it as the past is what has brought
it to this point Forrest calls it causal
determinism which states that as
everything is based upon natural laws
that are determined by definitive causes
that nothing is uncaused and therefore
everything has an effect if all causes
are known then we can follow the
after-effects back to where they were
caused and then use this information to
pull out a trajectory of where things
would continue to go I think the best
analogy I can think of is if you imagine
a book you can flick through the pages
and read the last one and work through a
backwards and the story will always be
the same because the events that
kick-started it led to a certain path
being fulfilled everything from your
past until now has happened because of
the domino effect in which certain
aspects all correctly fell into place
for you to be where you are now now we
could take your medical history your job
where you live your diet who you
socialize with and everything about you
and probably get a fairly accurate
prediction of how and when you will die
it's like those old guess your death
apps but far more sophisticated and no
things like that can be worrying for
some people a thing for the devs it's
very much a safety blanket that reminds
them that everything will happen the way
that it's supposed to so that's a basic
overview of how the machine works and as
I'm sure you can guess owning such a
thing would be extremely valuable now
before we get into the rest of the video
which discusses the multiverse aspect of
everything I just want to let you know
we're giving away a free copy of the
Star Wars Skywalker saga box set to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
being with a chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on devs in the
comment section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of April and the settle be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
prize it's the best of luck to everyone
who takes part ok so when we first see
the machine displaying events from the
past now you're extremely hazy and
difficult to make out this is because
the machine has to take into account a
number of different variables that it
cannot know for certain for example say
when trying to trace back your
grandparents you've got the hair color
one wrong ie thought your grandfather
was a ginger it would then think that
that would have to be other redheaded
people in your family to cause a
grandfather to be ginger so there would
be mistakes which would grow
exponentially the further back you went
instead of getting these completely
wrong the Machine accounts for these and
therefore it does not create a
crystal-clear image so we cannot look
back into the past exactly as it is
unlikely that it got absolutely
everything right so instead it just
leaves the variables in now in the show
Lyndon actually clears all these
variables and it creates a perfect image
as well as clear audio this is used with
an example of Jesus on the cross and
though everyone in the department is
flabbergasted Forrest is angered by it
in clearing the variables one is
presenting a version of the universe in
which a grandfather was ginger and they
traced it back as if it was a fact and
therefore everything happened the way
that it's displayed this may have been
the case but it may also not have been
the case and therefore it is not a true
depiction of the past rather a possible
past I'll use an example on screen right
now at the moment this looks like a mess
because it's impossible to tell what
color the smiley face really is this is
how the machine generates the past and
future however if I tell it for definite
that the face was purple in the past
then everything is okay and it
completely clears up however the machine
has no one telling it definite and
therefore it creates a problem that is
the multiverse forest does not really
believe in air because if he did then he
may have to accept that his daughter
exists out there and he's still not with
her I don't know if that's a completely
accurate character study of forests but
he does begin to torture himself with
the notion of what if Lyndon argues with
him and is expelled because of it and
the series really grapples with whether
there's one universe or a multitude of
them Lyndon even puts his life on the
line in Episode seven to prove the
multiverse exists in a way and though he
dies in this one universe that we see we
also see several other versions exist
alongside him this gives the idea of
quantum immortality which is a similar
experiment to Schrodinger's cat it
states that if you put your life on the
line in an experiment like the one we
see Lyndon attempt
there will be two outcomes either you
will live or die if you live the
experiment can be repeated again and
again with it causing multiple universes
to branch off from that very moment in
which you died since consciousness
ceases upon death you won't remember the
universes that you died in and instead
you will follow through the universes in
which you live making you immortal
during the experiment you do get this
notion with the death of the character
and it could also hint at how the show
will be going forward for the finale we
do know that Lily's death has been
predicted however it could be possible
that she will exist within a reality in
which she does not die I don't think
that the show will do that more I think
that the Machine will end with her
destroying it and this will be why it's
unable to predict past a certain point
there are a ton of avenues that devs can
take overall and it's a fascinating
series that I really enjoyed talking
about in this video and answer to the
question of what is it that the devs do
the answer is nothing they just let
things happen the way that they should
and in doing so Lily is a direct front
to them here is someone who like Linden
wants to prove that free will is
possible and this breaks everything at
the dev stand for thus showing that
humanity is not on the train tracks that
the Machine states we are now obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on dev so
comment below and let me know if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you stay locked
to the channel for our breakdown of the
finale right after it has we've also
been covering Westworld week by week so
if you haven't had a chance to check
those videos out yet then make sure you
watch them after this you want to
support the channel from as little as 99
cents a month then please click the join
button below
we massively appreciate you and as a
thank you you get access to content
early you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
whitey or click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon this is the channel for people
who are never missing television so if
that's the kind of thing you like you
need to subscribe to definition
thanks again for taking the time to
watch this you've been the best and I'll
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]